we know there's a lot of things that all
Disney Princesses have in common but one
thing is really sad the princesses have
no human friends now let's check out
this sad reason that Disney Princesses
don't have human friends the Disney
Princesses have a ton in common it's
really normal for a Disney princess to
not have a mom do you have daddy issues
mom they usually end up cursed or
kidnapped and they all have a unique
bond with animals but then we realized
something else why don't any of the
Disney Princesses have any real human
friends we decided to take a look and
figure this out
let's check out each princess to
discover the sad reasons that they just
can't make human friends snow white snow
white wasn't just the fairest of them
all she's also the original Disney
Princess and she set up all of our
exceptions for a great Disney movie Snow
White lives in a castle with her evil
stepmother who is also a sorceress even
though Snow White is a princess she is
kept totally isolated and she has to do
all the chores around the castle
that's one hard job the Evil Queen
demands that her Huntsman takes Snow
White to the woods and cut out her heart
repiy
but the Huntsman takes pity on Snow
White and she runs away but you know
White has had a unique bond with animals
they even help her clean where can we
get in on that
but then Snow White meets the Seven
Dwarves so technically our original
Disney Princess has human friends but
she doesn't meet them until after she
starts her adventure Sleeping Beauty
Princess Aurora was cursed from the time
she was a baby
Maleficent got all offended that she
wasn't invited to the princess's
birthday party but who wants an evil
fairy at a party anyway so she curses
Aurora to prick her finger and meet her
end at age 16 the good fairies are able
to change this she only has to fall
asleep until true love's kiss wakes her
up but they're still determined to keep
her raw receive so instead of being
raised as a princess in a castle
the fairies take her to a cottage in the
woods wait a second doesn't the King
have an army that could protect her
anyway Aurora spent her whole life with
just three fairies her only other
friends are woodland creatures more
animals
we're starting to see a trend here we
sure hope she made some friends after
she gets married to the prince
Cinderella when it comes to princesses
with tragic backstories cinderella might
have the saddest story yet Cinderella
lost her father at a young age she then
was raised by a wicked stepmother and
two terrible stepsisters she was
basically their slave oh yes and the
draperies but I just filled him again
only friends were mice and mice can't
talk back Cinderella was always alone
and it's so sad we can't imagine being
that lonely but she gets her happily
ever after her fairy godmother dresses
her up and sends her to the ball the
prince falls in love with her and
searches the whole kingdom to find her
but this is yet another princess who has
no friends Ariel things change a little
bit in the modern princess era Ariel was
not totally isolated
she had a whole bunch of sisters and she
lived in a mermaid Kingdom let's just
pretend here that mermaids are basically
humans Ariel just doesn't fit in she's
too busy being obsessed with life
outside the see the other mermaids think
she's strange so she doesn't really have
any peers her best friend is a fish
named flounder and she becomes friends
with a lobster named Sebastian but why
doesn't Ariel have any friends like her
at least one she becomes human and
marries Erik she'll probably meet some
people she likes Belle she really is a
funny girl that Belle at least that's
what everyone in her village thinks
about her fell from Beauty and the Beast
seems like she should have friends she's
friendly and smart but everyone thinks
she's so weird
we don't think it's weird to love to
read but apparently no one in Belle's
village enjoys a good book just because
Belle is shy doesn't mean she's strange
yet she has no human friends once she's
imprisoned by the Beast she makes
friends with all the enchanted household
items okay we know that technically mrs.
Potts and company are humans trapped in
a curse but they'll still doesn't make
these friends until she's in the middle
of her story thankfully once the curse
is broken everyone is happy and human
Jasmine another 90s Disney Princesses
jasmine and talk about isolated Jasmine
is not allowed to leave her palace at
all I've never done a thing on my own
I've never had a new real
friends she occasionally sneaks out in
disguise and part of the reason she
falls for Aladdin is that he takes her
on adventures how messed up is that that
jasmine is basically imprisoned in her
own home she only has her tiger Rajah
for companionship yep that is one more
princess with only an animal for a best
friend we vet things got a lot happier
for Jasmine after she ends up with
Aladdin Pocahontas when you think of a
Disney princess who loves animals you
probably think of Pocahontas this
nature-loving princess is one of the
first ones who doesn't need saving
instead she saves people and we hope
that earned her some friends but
Pocahontas is a misfit she doesn't want
to just get married to the next chief
she's too much of a leader for that her
best friends are animals especially Miko
the cutest raccoon ever she also has a
great friend in mother willow but she
isn't human either
mother willow is a tree Mulan Mulan is
sort of an exception to the no human
friends rule but she doesn't actually
have any friends as Mulan Mulan is not
your typical girl in Imperial China she
doesn't want to get married and have a
bunch of babies she wants more when she
goes to the matchmaker you can see how
much the other girls despise her it's
pretty sad but once Millan becomes pink
to take her father's place in the war
she makes friends with the other
soldiers but even they didn't like her
at first
thankfully they became really good
friends they stayed friends with Milan
even after realizing she was a girl
Merida the Pixar princess is different
from the other princesses in a lot of
ways this Scottish princess is the first
princess to have no love interest she
also has two living parents but she does
have one major similarity to the other
princesses she has no human friends she
spends most of her days being forced
into acting like a princess by her mom
or running off on her horse and having
adventures where are all the other kids
her age she just doesn't have any
friends at all she loves her horse but
he's not really a friend no wonder she
was excited to find those willow the
wisp maybe she thought they'd give her
some company Rapunzel
it's not Rapunzel's long hair that keeps
her from having human friends it's the
fact that she was kidnapped as a baby
and locked in a tower her whole life
talked about
messed up childhood Rapunzel thinks it's
for her safety even though she isn't
happy but really it's soap Mother Gothel
can keep getting the power from
Rapunzel's hair we bet if Rapunzel had a
normal childhood she would have had lots
of friends she's so fun and spunky in
the tower Rapunzel's only friend is her
lizard Pascal and he's so cute but he's
not the best company you know since he
can't talk anin elsa we know that the
two sisters from frozen have not been
officially dubbed disney princesses but
they are disney characters who aren't
princesses well Elsa becomes queen so we
are including them here after their
parents meet their tragic end Etsy Elsa
becomes totally isolated she stays in
her room all the time and she makes an
estate in the castle all the time - we
know there had to be some other kids in
the city but these two sisters were
total Hermits and what's really sad is
that Emma didn't want to be please
please I can't live like this anymore
she just wanted to be around people
Anna's first real friend is the snowman
Olaf why don't they have any friends
Milana Disney's latest princess is Moana
she's called by the sea to return the
heart of taffy tea and break a curse
affecting her people she's fierce and
adventurous and like Merida she has no
love story and both of her parents are
alive that's just so rare for a princess
but she doesn't really fit in in her
village she knows what her role is
supposed to be but she feels called for
more rope pony friends are a pig and
really stupid rooster hay hay is
hilarious
Milana has a whole village of people
there have to be some kids her age but
she doesn't have any human friends this
is getting weird Disney the theory we
have looked into all the princesses who
do not have human friends this question
isn't quite as easy to figure out as
some other princess theories for
instance we know that a lot of
princesses don't have moms but Walt
Disney lost his mom at a young age that
totally makes sense why he would include
that in his early movies and once Disney
starts a tradition it sticks so why are
there no human friends in the Disney
Princess movies the only answer is that
princesses have to be isolated in order
to earn that title Disney princess and
that is seriously messed up surely there
could be great fairy tales where the
character
have a normal group of friends right
Disney likes to create a tragic
backstory and they are good at it lost
parents being treated like a slave being
kidnapped those are all seriously
traumatic events but you know what's
really sad being lonely being lonely is
the most relatable sad thing Disney can
do everyone has felt lonely at some
point everyone has lost friends and felt
like an outsider even really little kids
understand this feeling Disney makes
such great characters because they're
relatable and we can totally feel for
them when they don't have friends
so is Disney just playing with our
feelings it sure seems that way
the exception if you're watching this
video and think we left out princesses
you're right there is one Disney
princess who breaks the no human friend
role and it's not that she gets human
friends later in life like Mulan and
Snow White which princess are we talking
about Tiana from Princess and the Frog
of course this hard-working princess
just wants to open a restaurant but
things get complicated when she kisses a
frog and turns into a frog herself she
goes on an adventure with Prince Naveen
and becomes human again but Tiana has
one human friend the daughter of the
family she works for charlotte la bouff
is a little ditzy and boy-crazy but
she's a good best friend they're total
opposite so why is Tiana allowed to have
a human friend she's still an outcast
she's not like Charlotte and the other
girls she wants to open a restaurant
instead of getting married we love that
she has a good friend though what do you
think about this weird trait that Disney
Princesses share did you ever notice it
let us know in the comments below send
this video to your best human friend to
let them know you're glad to have them
and that is the sad reason why the
Disney Princesses have no friends like
this video and don't forget to subscribe
see you next time
[Music]